Dr. Zakir Abdul Karim Naik
33 years
is the president of the Islamic Research
Foundation Bombay
a medical doctor by professional
training he has turned around to make
the proper clarification
as well as removing misconceptions about
Islam
his main mission in life he is a keen
student of Islam and comparative
religion
in the last three years itself Dr. Zakir
has delivered more than 300 public talks
abroad in addition to his many talks in
India. He has also participated in many
symposia and debates with prominent
personalities of other faith.
May I call upon Dr. Zakir to make his
presentation on the topic of the day
was Christ really crucified Dr. Zakir.
Alhamdulillah
Was Allah to Allah was Salam
Bismillah Rahman Rahim Rabbi Sharhili
Sadri Wa Yassir Li Amri Wahlul Uqdatan
Min Lisani Yafqahu Qawli.
Respected Pastor Ruknuddin or I would
like to be called Pastor Rocky
Henry Pio
Pastor Saji
the respected pastors from various
churches of Bombay
my respected elders
and my dear brothers and sisters
I welcome all of you
with Islamic greetings Assalamualaikum
Warahmatullahi Wabarakatuhu.
May peace mercy and blessings of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala of Almighty God be on
all of you.
Before I dwell into the topic
I would like to clarify the position of
Jesus peace be upon him in Islam.
Islam is the only non-Christian faith
which makes it an article of faith to
believe in Jesus peace be upon him.
No Muslim is a Muslim if he does not
believe in Jesus peace be upon him. We
believe that he was one of the mightiest
messengers of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala of
Almighty God.
We believe that he was the Messiah
translated Christ. We believe that he
was born miraculously without any male
intervention which many modern-day
Christians today do not believe.
We believe
that he gave life to the dead with God's
permission. We believe that he healed
those born blind and lepers with God's
permission.
One may ask
that if Muslims and Christians both love
and respect Jesus peace be upon him
then where is the parting of ways?
The major difference is
the Christians insistence
on the supposed divinity of Jesus peace
be upon him.
And they say that he was crucified on
the cross and he died for the sins of
humanity.
The topic
of today's debate
if you have forgotten is
was Christ really crucified?
And since we Muslims and Christians both
believe in Jesus peace be upon him it's
obligatory that we put forth
both points of view
the Muslim and the Christian points of
view.
As far as the Muslim point of view is
concerned
we believe
the most authentic and sacred book which
is the word of God is the glorious
Quran.
And I started my talk by reciting a
verse from the glorious Quran from Surah
Nisa chapter 4 verse 157 which
gives the verdict the Islamic viewpoint
regarding the topic of today's debate
was Christ really crucified?
And since
Pastor Rocky
he's an Arab Christian missionary
Arabic is his mother tongue
I do not have to translate the meaning
of what I recited in the beginning of my
talk
for him to realize to understand what is
the Islamic viewpoint.
But since
most of us
don't understand Arabic
Arabic is not a mother tongue I would
like to translate the verse which I
recited in the beginning of my talk from
Surah Nisa chapter number 4 verse number
157 which says Wa Qawlihim they said the
Jews in boast
Inna Qatalnal Masiha Isa ibn Maryam that
we killed Christ Jesus son of Mary the
messenger of Allah
Wa Ma Qataluhu Wa Ma Salabuhu
they did not kill him
neither did they crucify him Wa Lakkin
Shubbiha Lahum but it was made to appear
so.
Wa Inna Allazi Nakhtalifu Fihi Lafi
Shakkin Minhu
and all those who differ therein are
full of doubts
Ma Lahum Bihi Min Ilm with no certain
knowledge Illat Tibaa Az Zann
with only conjectures to follow Wa Ma
Qataluhu Yaqina for a surety they killed
him not.
This verse of the glorious Quran is so
explicit
unambiguous
making it very clear that the Islamic
viewpoint is Wa Ma Qataluhu Wa Ma
Salabuhu they killed him not neither did
they crucify him.
Wa Ma Qataluhu Yaqina for a surety they
killed him not.
No one can be more explicit
more unambiguous more unequivocal than
the Quran in this verse saying that he
was not killed.
If
I conclude my presentation right now
without commenting or refuting on the
biblical point of view what the pastor
has presented
as far as the debate is concerned
it will be a draw it will be neutral
that the Muslim say
according to the Quran Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was not really
crucified and the Christian according to
their understanding of the Bible they
say he was crucified it would be a draw
but I will not do that. I will prove
from the Bible itself
with the Christian belief to be the word
of God that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him was not really crucified.
Let me first clarify
that we Muslims
we do not consider the Bible to be the
word of God.
The Bible may contain certain portions
which
we may consider it to be the word of
God.
It contains the word of the prophets
the word of the historians
it also contains absurdity
obscene statements which if someone even
pays me a thousand rupees now I will not
be able to read from the Bible.
Such obscene
verses obscene chapters it also contains
contradictions.
But even though I don't believe that the
Bible is the word of God yet I will
prove from the Bible that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was not crucified
because Pastor Rocky
and many Christians out here
they agree the Bible to be the word of
God so I'll prove from their evidence.
Because
the Quran says in Surah Baqarah chapter
number 2 verse number 111
Wa Qalu La Yadkhulul Jannata Illa Man
Kana they say
the Jew and Christian you Muslims you
shall never enter Jannah
with all your piety with all your
righteousness as pastor said
with all the good deeds you shall not
get salvation that's what the pastor
said in his talk.
It's useless with all your zakat with
the hajj with the salah with the mark on
your forehead you shall never enter
Jannah
unless
you be a Jew or a Christian.
Wa Qalu La Yadkhulul Jannata Illa Man
Kana Hudan Aw Nasara unless you are a
Jew or a Christian.
Allah says Tilka Amani Yuhum this is the
wishful thinking Bakwase Bakwas vain
desires Qul tell them Hatu Burhanakum
produce your proof In Kuntum Sadiqeen
but if you're truthful.
Allah says ask them to produce their
proof if I tell from the Quran that
Jesus was not crucified the Christians
they don't agree the Quran to be the
word of God so we have to ask them Qul
Hatu Burhanakum produce your proof In
Kuntum Sadiqeen but if you're truthful
and the Christian
they have produced their proof
the Bible as the Burhan.
The Christian says my Bible says this my
Bible says that my Bible says this my
Bible says that. Let's analyze what does
the Bible says.
And they've produced this Bible in no
less than 2000 different languages of
the world.
So let's analyze from the Bible whether
the Christ was really crucified.
And while doing so whatever conclusion I
draw from the Bible need not necessarily
be the Islamic viewpoint let me remind
you that.
The conclusion drawn from the Bible need
not necessarily be the Islamic viewpoint
the Islamic viewpoint I have made it
very clear according to Surah Nisa
chapter 4 verse 157 Wa Ma Qataluhu Wa Ma
Salabuhu they killed him not neither did
they crucify.
It's clear cut.
The topic
was Christ really crucified?
What is the meaning
of
the English word crucify
according
to the Oxford dictionary
crucify means to put to death by
fastening onto the cross.
According to the Webster dictionary
crucify means
to put to death by nailing or binding to
the cross.
In short
for a person to be crucified, he should
die on the cross. If he does not die,
he is not crucified.
What is the meaning of the word
resurrection?
Resurrection
according to the Oxford dictionary means
the act
or instance of rising from the dead.
And resurrection with the capital R
means
Christ
rising from the dead.
According to the Webster dictionary,
resurrection means
the act of rising from the dead. And
resurrection with the capital R means
rising again of Christ after his death
and burial. In short
for Christ to be resurrected, he has to
die.
If he does not die,
he is not resurrected.
Let everyone get this definition is very
clear in their mind.
According
to Jesus, peace be upon him, he says in
the Gospel of Matthew chapter number 19
verse number 16 and 17
that a person can obtain salvation by
keeping the law and the commandments.
But according to St. Paul
he nails the laws and the commandments
to the cross cross cross cross as you
heard pastor sing cross cross. He nails
the law and the commandment to the cross
as he says in Colossians chapter number
two
verse number 14.
And Paul says
that
salvation can be obtained
by believing in the death and
resurrection of Jesus, peace be upon
him. And he quotes, if you read the New
Testament
First Corinthians chapter number 15
verse number 14. I give the reference so
that you know people realize I'm not
pulling a fast one. I prefer giving
references. Otherwise, if I say Bible
says this, New Testament says this in
this encyclopedia of more than a
thousand pages, where will you find?
To make it easy, I give references.
According to St. Paul
First Corinthians chapter number 15
verse number 14
and if Christ has not risen from the
dead
our preaching is in vain and your faith
is in vain.
As the pastor said
that all your good deeds, all your
charity without believing in Christ died
for the sin, it is useless.
And
the Christian missionaries, the
reference they didn't give quoting from
Isaiah
chapter number 64 verse number six that
all our righteousness, all our good
deeds are like filthy rags. If you don't
believe Jesus Christ, peace be upon him,
died on the cross for the sin of
humanity, all your righteousness, all
your good deeds are like filthy rags.
And in the words of the pastor, which I
wouldn't ever say, he says, if there is
no cross, if there is no crucifixion,
Bible is less than two pies.
And he says
if no crucifixion,
there's no Christianity.
And I agree with him.
And I agree with him. And the pastor
said that he came to India
and he spent more than two decades here.
And only when he came to India, he
really
realized the message of Christianity.
Previously, he was only a Christian, but
he became a practicing Christian from
the Muslims here.
I like to remind him
that I have only met one Arab Christian
before in my life before meeting pastor.
One Arab Christian I met in Jeddah from
Syria.
And after he attended my talk
alhamdulillah, by Allah's grace, he
accepted Islam.
This is the second time in my life that
personally I'm meeting an Arab
Christian.
And inshallah
with Allah's help, and I pray to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to give him hidayah
that since he got the teachings of
Christianity from the Indians, he will
come back to the original faith, which
is Islam, which every human being is
born in. Inshallah, after this talk,
after having discussion, inshallah, I
pray that he comes back to the original
faith
inshallah, realizing that if no
crucifixion, no cross, no Christianity.
But inshallah, I will do in the course
of my time.
Let's see what St. Paul has to say
regarding resurrection.
St. Paul
he comments on resurrected bodies
in the same chapter where he says if
Christ hasn't risen,
our faith is in vain, our preaching is
in vain. Same chapter
First Corinthians chapter 15 towards the
end of the chapter. St. Paul says in
First Corinthians
chapter 15 verse 42 to 44
he says
that so also
is the resurrection of the dead.
It is sown
in corruption, it is raised in
incorruption.
It is sown
in dishonor, it is raised in glory.
It is sown in weakness, it is raised in
power. It is sown a natural body, it is
raised a spiritual body. There's a
natural body and there's a spiritual
body.
According to St. Paul, the resurrected
bodies are spiritualized.
They are spiritualized.
Same is said by his Lord and master,
Jesus, peace be upon him, in the Gospel
of Luke chapter number 20 verse number
27 to 36. If you remember the story
of a woman who had seven husbands
and the Jews come with a poser to Jesus,
peace be upon him. And it's a Jewish
practice
that if a man marries a woman and if he
dies
without leaving any children, the second
brother
marries the wife
of the deceased brother so that he can
give her his seed.
If the second brother dies without
leaving any children, the third brother
marries so on and so forth. So here they
come with a poser that this woman
married seven brothers one after the
other.
And all of them had her year. Means they
had her as a wife here one after the
other. But there was no problem. Why?
Since each one of them had turn by turn,
so there was no problem.
And later on even she dies.
But they pose the question to Jesus,
peace be upon him, that in resurrection
who will have her there?
Indicating during resurrection, all the
seven brothers will be raised
simultaneously along with the woman, who
will have her there?
So Jesus, peace be upon him, says in the
Gospel of Luke chapter number 20 verse
35 and 36 that resurrected bodies, they
do not marry.
Neither do they give in marriage.
Verse 36 says that neither shall they
die anymore.
They are equal unto the angels. That
means they shall be angelized.
Resurrected body will be spiritualized.
Who says that? Jesus says that. Gospel
of Luke chapter number 20 verse 36. Paul
says that.
First Corinthians
chapter 15 verse number 42 to 44.
It's very clear.
And
there's not a single verse anywhere in
the Gospel
which says
that Jesus, peace be upon him, was
resurrected.
In fact, if you read
it's mentioned
if you remember
the story
that after the alleged crucifixion
when the disciples, they met in the
upper room
Jesus, peace be upon him, he comes. It's
mentioned in the Gospel of Luke chapter
number 24 verse number 36.
He comes and he says to the disciples,
"Shalom."
In Hebrew, which means peace unto you.
Next verse, Gospel of Luke chapter 24
verse 37 says
but they were terrified and affrighted
and supposed him to be a spirit.
I'm asking a question.
Why did the disciples
think Jesus, peace be upon him, to be a
spirit?
Did Jesus look like a spirit?
And when I ask this question to the
Christians, all of them said no.
And they are right. Jesus Christ, peace
be upon him, did not look like a spirit
when he come to the upper room after the
alleged crucifixion.
So why did they think that he was a
spirit? The reason is because they had
heard from hearsay that their master,
Jesus, peace be upon him, was put on the
cross.
They had learned from hearsay that he
had given up the ghost, that he had
died.
They had learned from hearsay that he
was dead and buried in the grave for
three days. Hearsay hearsay. You know
why? Because they were not eyewitnesses.
According to Mark, Gospel of Mark
chapter number 14 verse number 15, it
says that all of them forsook him and
fled. In the most crucial juncture in
the life of Jesus, peace be upon him,
when he required them the most
all the disciples, 100%
all of them according to Mark chapter 14
verse 50
they forsook him and fled.
Who says that? Not Dr. Zakir Naik.
Gospel of Mark chapter 14 verse number
50.
All of them forsook him. So it was from
hearsay.
Therefore, they think and they thought
that he was a spirit.
But Jesus, peace be upon him, to clarify
that out
it's mentioned in the next two verses in
the Gospel of Luke chapter number 24
verse number 39 and 40
Jesus, peace be upon him, says
that
behold my hands and feet
it is I myself. Handle me and see for a
spirit has no flesh and bone as you see
me have.
And seeing so, he shows them his hands
and feet.
He tells them
behold my hands and feet. It is I
myself. What has happened to you? It is
me, your lord and master Jesus, peace be
upon him. Why you afraid?
Handle me and see.
You hold my hands and feet for a spirit
has no flesh and bones. What was he
trying to prove by showing his hands and
feet?
Was he trying to prove that he was
resurrected? Was he trying to prove that
he was a spirit? He was trying to prove
that he was not a spirit.
He was not resurrected.
Next two verses.
Gospel of Luke
chapter number 24, verse number 41 to
42. It says that they were overjoyed and
they wondered.
They thought he's dead and now they're
happy that the lord and master is alive
physically with flesh and bone in front
of them.
They're happy.
Jesus, peace be upon him, yet to confirm
themselves.
That
"Do you have any meat here?" And they
gave him a piece of broiled fish and and
honeycomb.
And he took it and he ate before them.
To prove what?
That he was resurrected? To prove that
he was a spirit? To prove that he was a
physical body. He ate
and he chewed in front of them.
A piece of broiled fish and honeycomb to
prove that he was not resurrected. He
was not a spirit, but he was in flesh
and bones, a physical body.
If no resurrection, no crucifixion, no
Christian.
If you remember
the story of Mary Magdalene
when
she goes to the tomb of Jesus, peace be
upon him, on the third It's mentioned in
the Gospel of John
chapter number 20
verse number one
as well as the Gospel of Mark chapter
number 16, verse number two
that it was the first day of the week,
meaning it was a Sunday.
Sabbath day is
Saturday for the Jews. The first day of
the week is Sunday. It was the first day
of the week that Mary Magdalene goes to
the tomb.
Now, why should Mary Magdalene go to the
tomb on the third day
after
Jesus Christ, peace be upon him,
supposedly was dead? Why should she go?
The reply is given in the verse earlier
in the Gospel of Mark chapter number 16,
verse number one that Mary Magdalene
goes to massage Jesus, peace be upon
him, to anoint him.
The word is anoint, which the original
Hebrew word
is masaha, means to massage, to rub, to
anoint.
And from this root word, you can even
derive the Arabic word
masih
or the Hebrew word
Messiah which means the anointed one.
Which, if you translate to Greek, it
means Christos
from which you get the word Christ, the
anointed one.
I'm asking a question. Do Jews massage
dead bodies on the third day? Have you
anytime heard
Jews massaging dead bodies on the third
day? And the answer is no.
I'm asking the Christians. Do Christians
massage dead bodies on the third day?
And the answer is no. Do Muslims?
Do we massage dead bodies on the third
day? And the answer is no.
So, why is she going to the tomb
to massage Jesus who has died on the
third day according
to the Christians?
You know why? Because she was the only
one besides Joseph of Arimathea
and Nicodemus who gave the burial bath
to Jesus, peace be upon him. And when
Jesus' body was brought down, peace be
upon him, from the cross
she might have seen some life in the
limb body.
But naturally
she's not going to say, "He's alive."
Otherwise
they will put him to death again.
Seeing certain life in the limb body of
Jesus, peace be upon him
she comes back on the third day after
the Sabbath day
to look for
a live Jesus, peace be upon him.
A live Jesus, peace be upon him.
And
it's mentioned in the Gospel of John
chapter number 20, verse number one
and the Gospel of Mark chapter number
16, verse number four
that
she finds
that the stone has been removed.
And even
the winding sheets, they are unwound and
placed in a pile.
The question is, why should the stone be
removed?
And why should the winding sheets be
unwound and placed at the side, piled up
at the side?
If Jesus, peace be upon him, was
resurrected
as a spiritual body, does a spirit
require
the stone of the entry of the tomb to be
removed? If it's a spirit
doors cannot stop a spirit
from entering.
The stone need not be removed. Why was
the stone removed? And if a spirit has
to move, does it have to unwound the
winding sheets?
It's not required.
But if it's a physical body
the stone blocking the entry of the tomb
has to be removed.
The winding sheets have to be unwound
proving that Jesus, peace be upon him
the person who came out of the tomb was
a physical body.
And
the tomb was a private property of the
secret disciple of Joseph of Arimathea
who was rich and influential Jew.
And he had carved a big roomy tomb maybe
for himself for future.
In which Jesus, peace be upon him, was
kept.
The tomb or the sepulcher.
And according to Jim Bishop he says
Jim Bishop, not Bible Jim Bishop, says
it was very roomy, very big.
5 ft wide
7 ft in height and 15 ft in depth.
Why do you require a roomy tomb?
So that if anyone wants to help a
person, it can be done easily. These are
small rooms in Bombay. It is approx. 75
sq ft. 75 sq ft flat is big in Bombay.
We find five, six people living in that
room in Bombay, one of the most
expensive place in the world.
75 sq ft, you find four, five people
living in it. So, roomy enough if they
want to help
the person. Why would they want to help
a spiritual body?
Spiritual body doesn't need any help.
But naturally they wanted to help a
physical body.
Further, if you read
in the Gospel of John
chapter number 20, verse number 15
Jesus, he sees that
Mary Magdalene
from the earth, from terra firma, not
from the heaven, he sees her and she's
weeping.
And he comes to her and asks
"Woman
why weepest thou? Whom seekest thou?"
Knowing very well what is the reason,
but yet asking.
She says
"I supposed him to be a gardener."
She asks, "Hm?"
"Where have you taken him?
And laid him so that I may take him
away."
I'm asking a question. Why did Mary
Magdalene suppose Jesus, peace be upon
him, a gardener?
I'm asking a question. Do resurrected
bodies look like gardeners? Do they?
Yes or no?
No.
So, why should she suppose that Jesus,
peace be upon him, was a gardener?
And their answer is because he was
disguised as a gardener.
Now, why should a spiritual body be
disguised as a gardener?
Jesus Christ was disguised as a
gardener, peace be upon him, because he
was afraid of the Jews. A spiritual body
need not be afraid of the Jews. Why?
Because according to Hebrew
chapter number nine, verse 27 a man dies
only once
and after that
is the day of judgment.
Jesus, peace be upon him, said in the
Gospel of Luke chapter number 20, verse
number 36
"Neither shall you die anymore." If
you're a spiritual life, you don't have
to be afraid of anyone.
No one can harm you.
You cannot die a second time. If he's
spiritual life, why should he be
disguised?
Why should he be afraid? Why should he
be in hiding? Why should he run away
from the Jews?
Proving that he was not a spiritual
body, but he was alive.
And
he says to Mary, "Mary."
The one word is sufficient for Mary to
recognize
her lord and master.
You know, because everyone has a
particular style of calling the beloved
one.
And the tone and the style which you
call your beloved one is sufficient to
recognize who is the person.
She immediately recognizes that it is
Jesus, peace be upon him.
And she rushes forward to what him.
Gospel of
John chapter number 20, verse 15, 16,
17.
Jesus, peace be upon him, says, "Touch
me not."
Why?
Why touch me not?
Is he
a bundle of electricity that if someone
touches him
the person will be electrocuted?
Is he a bundle of dynamite that if
someone touches, they will blow up?
Why does he say touch me not?
Because
he was a physical body. Imagine the
ordeal, the pain, the physical pain, the
emotional pressure that he had going
through all that so-called, supposedly
put on the cross, put on the cross, all
that pain and torture. It will hurt a
physical body. He says, "Touch me not."
And then continues and says
in the Gospel of John chapter 20, verse
number 17
"I have not yet ascended unto my
father."
Meaning what?
That he has not yet been dead.
Jesus Christ, peace be upon him,
unequivocally says that he has not yet
been resurrected.
Proving that he was alive.
Later on it's mentioned
in the Gospel of Mark
chapter number 16
verse number 11
that the disciples, they had heard that
Jesus, peace be upon him, was alive.
From
her, Mary Magdalene, but they believed
not.
You know, the Jews, they had a habit of
posing questions, troubling the
messengers. The Quran says that, the
Bible says that. They posed questions to
Moses, peace be upon him. They troubled
him and they harassed him. Same they did
Jesus, peace be upon him.
Further, it's mentioned in the Gospel of
Matthew,
chapter number 12,
verse number 38, the Jews come up to
Jesus, peace be upon him, say, "Master,
rabbi, meaning oh lord,
why don't you give us a sign?"
Sign meaning a miracle.
Miracle.
All the good works that Jesus Christ,
peace be upon him, did was not
sufficient to convince the Jews. They
said, "Give us a sign. Give us a
miracle."
Maybe
like flying in the air,
like walking on the water,
like walking on burning charcoal. They
wanted some miracle.
Sign here doesn't mean a sign on a lamp
post, you know, like you have signs
on the roads, it's not that sign. It
particularly means a miracle. And if you
read the New International Version, it
says a miraculous sign.
What is the reply Jesus, peace be upon
him, give?
What is the reply he gives?
In the next verse,
Gospel of Matthew, chapter number 12,
verse number 39 and 40, he says,
"You evil and adulterous generation,
seek it be after a sign?
You seek for a miracle? No sign shall be
given to you but the sign of Jonah. For
as Jonah was three days and three nights
in the belly of the whale,
so shall the son of man be three days
and three nights in the heart of the
earth."
Jesus, peace be upon him, doesn't say
that see, go and meet Bartimaeus,
the blind person who I gave sight. Why
don't you ask the woman with issues
who only on touching me she was healed.
He didn't refer to
the 2,000 pigs he had killed
to heal a possessed man. He doesn't say
that the 5,000 and the 3,000 people he
fed with
a boiled fish
and with bread.
He says, "No sign shall be given to you
but the sign of Jonah." Jesus, peace be
upon him, is putting all his eggs in one
basket.
The sign of Jonah.
And for a person
to know the sign of Jonah,
he doesn't have to be a scholar of the
Bible.
He doesn't have to be a doctor of
divinity because
it is taught in Sunday schools. And in
most countries, including India,
irrespective whether you're a Christian
or a Muslim or a Hindu, somewhere or the
other it is taught either in comics
or in moral science lessons, the sign of
Jonah
or Jonah and the whale.
They know.
But if you want to know the sign of
Jonah actually
in the Bible,
in this
big book,
the sign of Jonah
is less than two pages, less than one
and a half page.
I had the Xerox copy done from the same
Bible to make it easy.
Less than
one and a half side.
Less than one and a half side. Only four
chapters.
And to find one page in encyclopedia of
2,000 pages is difficult.
But everyone knows the outline of the
story.
That almighty God,
he asks his messenger, Jonah, peace be
upon him,
to go and deliver the message to the
Ninevites, to go to Nineveh.
But he says, "These Ninevites,
they
are so sinful, what will they listen to
the message?"
He thinks that they will make fun of me.
It'll be a waste of time. So he goes to
Joppa and from there he's setting sail
to Tarshish.
Now while he's at sea, there's a huge
storm.
And it was the superstition of the
marines of that time that if there's a
storm at sea, it is because someone has
disobeyed the master.
And they had their own ways in trying to
find who was the person responsible.
They had the system of casting of lots.
And when they cast lots,
it comes to the turn of Jonah, peace be
upon him. And Jonah, being a messenger
of almighty God, he agrees and he says
that see, I'm the person responsible. I
was told by my master, lord, to go to
Nineveh, but from Joppa I'm setting sail
to Tarshish, running away. I'm at fault.
You take me and throw me overboard.
But they say, "This person, such a pious
person,
why should simply he be killed?" So they
try and stop the ship, but yet they are
not successful, the storm is yet there.
So he says that why don't you throw me
overboard? And finally they agree and
they throw him overboard.
When they throw him overboard, the storm
subsides.
Maybe it was a coincidence.
Later on, a big fish, a whale comes and
swallows Jonah, peace be upon him.
Jonah prays to almighty God from the
belly of the whale.
The whale takes Jonah, peace be upon
him, for three days and three nights
round the ocean and then vomits him out
on the seashore.
What was the sign of Jonah, Jesus, peace
be upon him, says?
That no sign shall be given to you but
the sign of Jonah. For as Jonah was
three days and three nights in the belly
of the whale, so shall the son of man be
three days and three nights in the heart
of the earth.
Now I'd like to ask you a question.
When Jonah was thrown overboard,
was he dead or alive? Before you answer,
I'd like to make it easy for you. That
see, Jonah volunteers. He says, "I'm the
culprit. I'm responsible. Throw me
overboard." If someone doesn't agree,
maybe you have to break his leg. You may
have to break his
his neck. You may have to twist his arm.
But here he volunteers, so they don't
have to do all that. So they throw him
overboard. I'm asking you a question,
when Jonah was thrown overboard, was he
dead or was he alive?
Alive.
The fish comes and swallows him. Was he
dead or alive?
Alive.
He prays to almighty God from the belly
of the whale.
Was he dead or alive? Do dead men pray?
Was he dead or alive?
Alive.
The whale takes Jonah three days and
three nights in the ocean. Dead or
alive?
Alive.
Fish vomits him out on the seashore. Was
he dead or alive?
Alive. Alive, alive, alive, alive. When
a person is thrown overboard in a raging
sea, he ought to die. If he dies, no
miracle. If he's alive, it's a miracle.
Fish comes and swallows him.
He ought to die. He doesn't die. It's a
miracle.
Three days and three nights, suffocation
and heat in the belly of the whale, he
ought to die. He doesn't die. It's a
miracle. It's a miracle of a miracle of
a miracle.
Miracle of a miracle of a miracle.
Jesus said, peace be upon him, "As Jonah
was three days and three nights, so
shall the son of man be three days and
three nights."
As Jonah was three days and three nights
in the belly of the whale, so shall the
son of man be three days and three
nights in the heart of the earth. Jonah
was alive. But when I pose the question
to my Christian brothers, and they are
our brothers, they are our cousins, what
do you call?
They are brothers. When I pose the
question to the Christians that how was
Jesus, peace be upon him, in the tomb
according to you, and all of them say
that he was dead.
He was dead.
I'm asking you a question, Jonah was
alive.
Jesus, peace be upon him, was dead.
So was Jesus, peace be upon him, alike
or unlike Jonah?
Like or unlike?
Unlike.
So Jesus, peace be upon him, does not
fulfill the prophecy.
He puts all his egg in one basket and
says no sign shall be given but the sign
of Jonah.
And here the prophecy is not fulfilled.
For the prophecy to be fulfilled, he
should be alive. As I proved in the
earlier part of my talk, he was alive.
Otherwise, Jesus, peace be upon him,
will be a liar, knows better, which we
cannot agree.
We respect him. We revere him. So for
him to fulfill the prophecy, he should
be alive. And Jesus, peace be upon him,
was alive as I proved in the earlier
part of my talk.
As I said,
that for a person to be crucified,
he
should
be put to death on the cross. If he does
not die on the cross, he is not
crucified.
There are some people
who may say that see, here the main part
of the sign is not dead or alive, it's
the time factor, time factor.
You know, three days and three nights,
as Jonah was in the belly of the whale,
so shall the son of man be three days
and three nights. Three is mentioned
four times. The main important emphasis
is three, three, three.
It is not dead or alive. I say, "What is
so unique about three? If I say I took
three days and three nights to reach
Delhi,
is it a miracle?
What is so miracle about three? Three
days or three weeks, it's not a
miracle." But they say, "No, it is a
time factor." Let's analyze whether
Jesus Christ, peace be upon him,
fulfills the time factor which the
Christians, some Christians, say is the
main theme of the sign.
As I said earlier,
and we know that when we ask the
Christians
that
when was Jesus Christ, peace be upon
him, crucified, and according to the
Bible, the Christians will say
on a Good Friday. So we ask him, "What
is so good about the Friday?" They say
Jesus Christ, peace be upon him, died
for our sins.
Therefore it's a Good Friday.
And if you read that it was the trial
was in a hurry. They were hurry for the
trial. They were in a hurry to put him
up on the cross. They were hurry to get
him down because as pastor said, no one
can stay overnight hanging on the cross
on the Sabbath according to, he didn't
mention the reference, Deuteronomy
chapter number 21, verse number 23. The
land will get cursed.
So they were hurry to get him down.
And they give the burial bath and it is
by the time late in the evening. He's
put in the sepulcher
late in in evening. And according to
Gospel of John chapter 20 verse 21,
it was the first day of the week, Sunday
morning, that the tomb was found empty
by Mary Magdalene.
So, supposedly, Jesus was in the tomb
on Friday night.
Why do I say supposedly? Because the
Bible does not say when does Jesus leave
the tomb. Maybe he left on Friday late
night or Saturday morning. It doesn't
say.
Agreeing that latest might have left is
in early morning on Sunday.
So, Jesus was in the tomb Friday night.
Supposedly, he was there in the tomb
Saturday day.
Saturday night.
Supposedly, Sunday morning the tomb is
empty. So, he was there for two nights
and one day.
But the sign says three days and three
nights. Three days and three nights.
As Jonah
was in the belly of the whale, so shall
the son of man be in the heart of the
earth. Three days and three nights. But
Jesus, peace be upon him, was actually
one day and two nights.
Is three days and three nights equal to
one day and two nights? Is it equal?
Three days three nights equal? No. So,
even the time factor which they boast
about is not fulfilled.
The real thing is Jesus Christ, peace be
upon him, was alive. For a person to be
crucified, he should die on the cross.
Just to make easy for the pastor in the
limited time he has, I'll list the major
points proving that he was not
crucified, he was not resurrected.
Because he was alive. If he's alive, no
crucifixion, no resurrection.
He was put on the cross and brought down
very fast
in 3 hours. In 3 hours it's difficult
for a person to die. Therefore, Jesus
was alive. When he's brought down, even
his two crossmates, they are alive,
proving that even Jesus was alive. Point
number two.
Point number three, his legs were not
broken.
What use
is a broken leg to a dead man, proving
that he was alive? Point number four,
that the stone was removed and the
winding sheets were unwound, proving
that Jesus, peace be upon him, was
alive. Point number five,
that he was disguised as a gardener.
Why?
Because he was alive, trying to be saved
from the Jews.
Point number six, the tomb was roomy.
It was spacious. What use is a spacious
tomb for a dead person, proving Jesus
was
alive? Point number seven,
that when Mary Magdalene goes to touch
Jesus, peace be upon him, he says,
"Touch me not."
Why? He was a physical body. He was
alive. It would hurt him. He was in
pain. Proving that he was alive.
Jesus, peace be upon him, says that I
have not yet ascended unto my father.
That means he was alive.
Point number nine, Mary Magdalene not
afraid to recognize him, Jesus, peace be
upon him. Point number 10,
that in the upper room,
he shows his hands and feet to prove
that he was not a spirit, but he was
alive.
Point number 11,
that
they were overjoyed to see him.
Why?
Because they thought he's dead in the
spirit form. They were overjoyed to see
because he was alive.
Point number 12, he ate
a piece of broiled fish and honeycomb to
prove that he was alive.
The disciples had heard
from Mary Magdalene that he was alive.
Point number 14,
the sign of Jonah. As Jonah was three
days and three nights in the belly of
the whale, so shall the son of man be
three days and three nights in the heart
of the earth. Alive, alive, alive. If
he's alive, no crucifixion, no
resurrection.
So, in short, Jesus Christ, peace be
upon him, was put on the cross according
to the Bible, but he did not die.
Now, the topic is was Christ really
crucified?
If he's put on the cross and if he dies,
he's crucified. If he's put on the cross
and does not die,
what is one word that we'll use? See,
English language
is deficient. If you look up in the
dictionary for a word for a person who's
put on the cross but does not die, you
will not find any word. So, we have to
coin new word. The best word that we can
coin is that Jesus Christ, peace be upon
him, was not crucified, but he was
crucificted.
It is not crucifixion, c r u c i f i x i
o n, but it is crucifiction,
c r u c i f i c t i o n. It's a fiction.
We have to coin a new word. So, Jesus
Christ, peace be upon him, was not
crucifixed, he was crucificted.
So, I hope this ends the friction
and the pastor will agree
and the confusion will be removed from
his mind that Jesus Christ, peace be
upon him, was not crucified.
There's no crucifixion, f i x i o n, but
crucifixion, f i c t i o n. I'd like to
end my talk by giving the quotation of
the glorious Quran from Sura Al Imran,
chapter number three, verse number 54,
which says, "Wa makaru wa makara Allahu,
wa Allahu khairul makireen." They
planned and plotted. Allah too planned.
Allah is the best of planners. Wa akhiru
da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil alameen.
Concerning that capital R and small r in
the dictionary, I have not examined that
point, but from Dr. Zakir's words, I get
it, resurrection with capital I is given
as an example of resurrection, and I
think he misunderstood it. He may not
agree with the dictionary, I may not
agree, but he has to agree with the
Bible. Saint Paul says that in 1
Corinthians, chapter number 15, verse
number 44, that resurrected bodies are
spiritualized. Does he believe in Jesus
or not? Paul talking particularly not
the commandment itself.
He's talking about
what the commandment has passed judgment
on me because I am a sinner. That list
of my judgments because of the
commandments, that's the one that fell
on Jesus on the cross. Paul says nailed
to the cross.
And pastor said, "All your good deeds
are useless."
If no crucifixion,
Bible is less than two pies. Dr. Zakir
is saying that nowhere in the Bible say
Jesus rose from the dead. I was so
shocked to hear that. Took me just 1
second to locate it and my pastor
located He quoted Gospel of Matthew
chapter 28,
verse
number six, he said, and I'm reading it,
"He is not here, for he is risen, as he
said. Come see
the place where the Lord lay." Risen
means he's alive.
I sleep and I rise.
Does it mean I'm resurrected? Why did
Jesus show his hand?
He wanted to show something special on
his hand. There was a There was a hole
in his hand. He doesn't say see the mark
on the hand itself nails. That's what
he's saying. That's what Thomas wanted.
Thomas wanted to see.
In the upper room, he shows to say, "I
am not a spirit." To prove what? He was
not resurrected. It is very clearly
mentioned the angel of the Lord removed
the stone. I didn't ask who removed the
stone.
I asked why was it removed? And the
pastor said, "To show to the people that
Jesus is not there." Why was it
necessary for the winding sheets to be
unwound?
The question is clubbed together. Stone
removed and winding sheets unwound.
Jesus said, "Like Jonah was in the tomb
in the whale 3 days and so and so."
Jesus did not say, "I'm going to be put
in the whale's mouth."
I think you cannot understand the plain
English what Jesus said. "As Jonah was
three days and three nights in the belly
of the whale, so shall the son of man be
three days and three nights in the heart
of the earth."
So, where is the question of he going in
the belly of the whale? Whether you pick
up the Marathi Bible or the Urdu Bible,
the original Hebrew statement is there,
"Eli Eli lama sabachthani?" And then the
translation, "Oh God, oh God, why have
thou forsaken me?" To prove that Jesus
Christ, peace be upon him, did not bring
the Quran.
said my pastor that
a true believer in Jesus Christ will
never become a rapist tomorrow.
But if you see the Christian on a whole,
you see that every Christian do sin. So,
that means you're trying to say that no
Christian is a true believer of Jesus
Christ?
I'm talking about the Bible Christians,
those who believe in the Bible. Can a
person bear someone else's sins? I
cannot be held responsible for my
father's sin, neither can my father be
held responsible for my sin. I can kill
you right now here, huh? And I can tell
tomorrow into the court that Mr. Jesus
is crucified for my sins, and you cannot
testify me.
Huh?
Then can you write on the paper that he
this guy should not be testified as Mr.
Jesus already crucified for him?
If you really believed, you will not
kill me. Debate subject what we have
today is was Christ really crucified?
Asking a counter question is not the
answer for the question. It's a simple
logical theory.
The subject of today is not whether
Jesus has
resurrected or not. I do not have
another debate whether the Christ was
resurrected or not.
Two birds with one stone.
If he did not die, he was not crucified.
If he did not die, he was not
resurrected. Which version of the Bible
is a correct? You have different
versions, and what language is the Bible
is mentioned? Brother has asked a very
complicated question. No, it's a simple
question. It's a simple question. And
one day we'll go for a chaiwala, sit
together and discuss it together. Okay.